where the attacker was killed by Israeli
police a driver as well we believe was
driving him to the scene well he was
arrested he was stopped and arrested by
Israeli forces as well leaving the scene
we don't know much more about the two
attackers or the motive but of course it
does come just a day after that attack
by Israeli forces in the West Bank City
of Janine the national security minister
itamar bengavir a controversial
far-right politician investing
netanyahu's new government has been here
at the scene in the last few minutes it
is going to be a big first test for him
and what he says is going to be far
harder policies towards the Palestinian
people the US ambassador I'm just
reading on Twitter has condemned it as a
horrific act of violence I'm shocked and
disgusted at this heinous terrorist
attack on innocent people including
children he said and talking about the
Americans and the situation here the U.S
Secretary of State Anthony blinken is
flying to the region later this weekend
he'll visit Egypt first one of the main
mediators between Israelis and the
Palestinians and then he'll come here to
Jerusalem and down the road to Ramallah
to speak to the Israelis and the
Palestinians he'll come with a message
from the White House a message from
President Biden that steps must be taken
to de-escalate the situation in Israel
and the West Bank but at the moment it
is incredibly tense here after a violent
two days